I'm Paul I also help organize London
Gophers so some of you may recognize me
from there but I'm going to talk to you
today about code generation in fact
writing less code which is something
hopefully we all want to do so what are
we going to do today we're going to
examine the principles of code
generation discover the main parts of a
code generator look at some popular code
generators see how code generation fits
into our workflow write a simple code
generator and as Michael kindly
introduced inspire everybody to join the
Go main tools community so why are we
doing this well the idea is that adding
in my opinion adding code generation to
your toolset effectively what you can do
when you're writing code is a really
powerful tool because as it says as I'll
go on to explain it allows you to write
less code and actually do things more
reliably so what do we mean by code
generation well code generation is the
process of generating code there we go
simple as that and code generators are
the things that generate the code here
endeth the lesson so we understand what
code generation is here so I'm going to
come back to this flow diagram over the
next couple of slides quite a bit
actually we've got an input on the left
and then an output on the right hand
side and the code generator just sitting
in the middle there so what what are
code generators who are code generator
water code generators well has anybody
written any go code great everyone in
here is a code generator of source and
humans are very good code generators
because we're very creative when it
comes to solving and thinking about
complex problems but we're not very good
at repetitive robotic tasks in fact I
really hate repetitive robotic tasks
particularly when it comes to writing
code so that's why I'm a big fan of code
generation but we're lucky because
computers are really good a repetitive
robotic tasks and that's where we can
write programs that can also be code
generators computers aren't at the
moment and let's not sort of dwell on
this point too much so good on the
creative and problem something side of
things but as I said this repetitive
robotic part they are very good at so
let's take advantage of that we can
write programs really complex things
like Bitcoin haha and all that type of
thing let's
right programs as well for simple things
like generating code might not be quite
as fun but it's extremely good for your
productivity so what can be generated
well absolutely anything if you think
about it we're talking about code
generation today but of course programs
can generate anything could be images
could be code whatever you like so we've
talked about the outputs and the
cogeneration sales well what about the
inputs well they can actually be zero
inputs to a code remote if you think
about it so is anybody here used to hugo
yeah plenty of good good number of
people actually use hugo the zero input
if you like to a code generator that
generates a template for you you've
literally just run a program and it
generates some code for you as a
starting point so that is in effect a
code generator
maybe you provided some configuration
maybe you provided a command line flag
all of these things are different sorts
of inputs to a code generator and that's
what we're looking at so what are we
going to focus on today or today we're
going to focus on go based code
generation that is as you can see on the
right hand side they're generating go
code using a code generator written in
go using as our input go source code so
this might seem a bit sort of
counterintuitive but well it'll become
clear as we go so let's look at some
examples of code generators that exist
out there in the wild to make this a bit
more concrete so at the top there you
might be slightly surprised to see go
test is actually a code generator in
itself the input files to go test the
code generator are the underscore test
go files that we all write and love and
the output is actually a main package
that gets compiled and run for you by
the go test command you can see some
other code generators there as well
if anybody's used G RPC protocol buffers
compiler is a very common one that you
might have come across we're going to
focus on the last one today which is
stringer and we're gonna use that as our
motivating example to understand a think
a bit more about why cogeneration is a
good thing
so stringer automates the creation and
methods that satisfy the string or
interface has received there and it
takes as its input again focusing the
input here the name of a type T and
that's an integer type that has some
constants defined of that type and then
it generates for us this string method
is we can see
the bottom here so why is this a
particularly problem why are we even
talking about this well let's take a
look at it this was a motivating example
a bit more here we have a type pill I'm
no pharmacist here neither am i
advocating drug use so let's let's not
dwell on this too much here and this
type pill we've also defined some
constants of that type as well so a
placebo aspirin ibuprofen and
paracetamol and if you look then we've
just simple function a main function at
the bottom there where we're getting
giving some advice to somebody on the
fact that they should take two something
per day the slight problem as you can
see in this very tight example is that
we have the message it says you need to
take to two per day well clearly that's
not very good it's not particularly
useful because who actually gave this
constant a name as well and it's been
lost here so this integer being output
for us is not particularly useful
particularly when we went to the effort
of giving it a sense of what a useful
exported name in this case in the code
so we can easily fix this of course
because we use the percent V verb there
and the func printf we can fix this by
writing ourselves a string function by
hand a string method excuse me by hand
but this is clearly going to get very
boring and it's very error-prone and it
easily gets out of date is somebody
they've got to think about I've now also
got to go and update the string method
as well so this is what I'm talking
about the repetitive robotic tasks and
this is just an example of that and so
this is where cogeneration comes in mrs.
West stringer the code generator comes
in as well our stringer lives in the
tools repository and it's very simply
installed and as we can see here one
that we actually come to run stringer
there's a number of flags there that we
can specify different parameters ie
inputs to the tool itself but all we're
gonna do here is provide the - type flag
here which tells stringer which type
within our source code it should look at
- code you write the string method for
us here
so let's actually run the tool as we
have at the bottom there string and -
type equals pill and we're just running
this from the command lines for now and
let's take a look at the output now the
output here is significantly more
involved than the code that we
by hand but this is also kind of part of
the the beauty of cogeneration as well
is that the complexity of a number of
nice features of this code here are
totally hidden for you by the code
generator okay so rather than having to
write something like this by hand every
single time the code generator is hiding
that complexity for you so I'm not even
going to go through all this code here
because that's not the point of this
presentation the point of this
presentation is actually to advocate the
use of code generators because it allows
you to do that right once and reuse many
times of this generation of this sort of
optimized code here so the workflow
though however of running stringer every
single time per package etc that's
clearly also something we're likely to
get wrong we're gonna forget to do it
it's easy it's complex to run across
many packages we've got to write run
things in certain orders maybe we've got
multiple code generators per package
again this also seems very error-prone
so how can we do better well this is
where I'm one of these sub commands of
the ego command called go check the goat
called generate comes in excuse me that
helps us to automate the process of
running code generators so instead of as
we saw running it by hand we're now just
going to run go generate and it's going
to take care of from running these code
generators for us so the goq the
generates sub command actually finds out
what to do by special comments called
directives and the code and you can see
one there and so the beauty here again
is that these directives to the generate
command actually live alongside the code
we're actually declaring things like the
type pill in this situation so instead
of it being in some make file which is
very 90s we're actually putting these
comments into our code and so alongside
the type definition we can have this go
generate directive which says well this
is how we're going to do something with
this type view and it's very clear as
well what code generator we're going to
use and then as you can see at the
bottom all we're going to do is run go
generate and we're gonna give it a list
of packages on which to run and here
we're just saying all the packages in
our module
quick refresh on the go tool however
it's important to note the cogeneration
is not part of the build process now
some people find there's a bit
contentious but it's the only thing to
remember now is it it's a step you must
explicitly run before you do it anything
that is billed related I build test
install etc so must run it explicitly
before but go generates encapsulate sand
wraps up the complexity of which tools
which code generators to run in which
packages for example one slight snag
there is no dependency analysis so if
you have package a that imports package
B and both of those actually do
cogeneration go generate won't actually
run those in the right order
ie be before a but we'll come to that
later on so let's have a quick recap on
where we are now we understand what
cogeneration is that was fairly simple I
was on the first right so we've seen one
example of where and why it's useful and
hopefully everybody's somewhat motivated
by that I don't see you getting very
excited about it but at the same time it
is actually useful we don't want to be
writing all this stuff robotic code
repetitively by hand each time so I
think we can perhaps all somewhat
subscribe to the the thinking that
actually cogeneration is a good thing
and we've also seen how go generate can
help with the workflow side of things
because again we don't want to have to
be remembering all the different flags
etc that we pass to our code generators
so let's actually write our own simple
code generator called simple stringer
we've been using string as our
motivating example let's carry on so
very simply simple stream is going to
behave in exactly it should behave and
have outputs that behave in the same way
as stringer I should generate for us a
string method on a type so we're just
going to bury it slightly here instead
of taking a flag we're actually going to
have an argument the simple stringer
simple string will then find all the
constants that have that type and
declared within our package and then
it's gonna define the string method
within that same package exactly the
same way that stringer did the actual
code that's output is clearly not
necessarily given it doesn't have to be
identical to that as stringer and as
we'll see it won't but it should behave
in the same way I if we call the string
method
should behave as it did before so what
simple string you're not gonna do well
this is a very simple example here so
it's not going to handle errors at all
gracefully / at all the codes probably
not going to be very pretty
we're definitely not going to cover any
edge cases here so don't judge me on
what the code you're about the CEO makes
few slides here Michael gave a really
good introduction here to effectively
the layers of abstraction that we
understand when we're looking at code so
everybody understands what a directory
is and within a directory and we have
files and then as we're all familiar as
well we can effectively consider a file
to be a slice of bytes wonderful better
word as the compiler then looks at our
that the source files that we pass to it
it then moves up these layers of
abstraction here or creates these layers
of abstraction for the jobs that the
compiler does our code generator is
going to do much the same here so we
don't need to worry about the details of
this here is that all we know is all I
want to convey by the slide here is as
we move up each layer here we're
learning more about the source code are
the packages that have been provided to
us and that's exactly what our code
generator is going to want to do as well
we're not just interested in the fact
that file a dot go exists we're
interested in the contents of the file
we're interested in not just the
contents in terms of a slice of bytes
you can see we're sort of looking to get
a higher-level representation of a
package so part of that as this slide
here indicates is the abstract syntax
tree which the go ast package allows us
to look at and good way of trying to
understand what the abstract syntax tree
is in terms of a representation of our
code is using a tool like this where we
have got a visual representation of what
the abstract syntax tree is because it's
somewhat counterintuitive if you've not
looked at an abstract syntax tree before
so if you haven't I'd encourage people
to just play around by like using this
tool here write some code in the
left-hand pane and then the right-hand
pane you can actually see our the
abstract syntax tree represents this
code in the following way here as
Michael also introduced the layer above
that is looking at types and simple
string and we'll use both the syntax
tree and types as part of generating the
output
so let's just jump straight into the
implementation here I'm not gonna do a
live demo because that would go horribly
wrong this is a bit let's think about
it's a code generator it's a program
therefore it's a func main so let's just
get very basic defiant declare a func
main here we need to take in an argument
which is going to be the types name
that's exactly what we do there and
we've you declare a variable to actually
gather the names of the constants of the
type that has been passed in good start
so now as I say we asked our we're going
to need to look at the structure of the
code and that's what I'm going to refer
to is the abstract syntax tree and also
the types that we see within our code
either types of expressions within that
code this is the code that the source if
you like where we've declared our type
pill so this code here I'm not going to
go into the detail but I'm just sort of
presenting these bits as blocks of the
program for people to effectively refer
to later on here here we're actually
loading that syntax and type information
and we're going to do that using go
packages as we see here go packages is
responsible for we've got these files on
disk and it's going to give us back this
abstract syntax tree representation it's
also going to allow us to query types
within that syntax tree as well so
that's all taken care of us on that for
us on that slide there so now the next
bit is actually saying what we've been
given this type name as an input to our
code generator we need to find that type
where is that type declared and for that
we actually use the type information and
here we're just looking in the scope
that is the package scope for the code
that has been loaded here the package
where we're code generating so that's
nice and simple we have that type in
hands now so now what we're trying to do
is very fine we've got this type I now
need to find all constants that are
declared with this type so if you think
about how you would actually do that
while you think well so find the
constants we're interested in are going
to be those the declarations at the top
level of the file and it should be some
name which has then got a type after it
and then some value to the right hand
side and that's exactly what we then do
by walking the structure are the
abstract syntax tree of all of the files
in a package
so that's exactly what happens here
again I'm not going to go into the
detail of this but I just described at a
high level what we're doing the syntax
here is that the syntax of the package
that we've loaded we're then walking
over each of the files and then we're
walking over each of the declarations
the top-level declarations within that
file as you can see we're then only
interested in the constant declarations
and within that we're only interested in
those contexts excuse me the constant
declarations that are of the required
type nice and simple so we've got these
building blocks and these slides will
all be available at the end that we're
putting together now so as you can see
well then adding to that slice we
declared at the beginning we're
gathering the names of the constants as
we go here and at the bottom we're just
sorting it for good measure so that we
have effectively well-defined order on
our output so now we've effectively
gathered the names of these constant
types but gather the names of the
constants excuse me so now we actually
need to generate the code itself now
lots of different ways of doing this but
one of my preferred ways is just simply
to write a template and then execute the
template it's nice and simple and you
can pretty much see here how simple it
is we could have format dot print lines
that words just repeatedly print print
print but for me it's always simpler to
say well I can look at this holistically
here in the template it's very clear if
I generate the wrong thing well guess
what it's not going to compile so I can
easily go back in fix the templates and
just iterate on things that way here
we've declared ourselves a template for
the output super simple this looks very
like a handwritten version if you
remember that we have before for anyone
who's not familiar this is using the
text template package here so that's a
quick place to go and take a look if
you're not familiar familiar with the
text with excuse me with the template
format so now all we need to just gather
a value that we're going to pass when we
execute the template we've done all the
hard work here the package name is given
for us by go packages the type name well
that was provided for us as an argument
and we've gathered the constant names as
we've been walking the syntax tree so
now all we're going to do is create an
output file execute the template and
format the result formatting the result
for good measure
because guess what it's nice to look at
it should be possible to look at this
generated code and for it not to be so
jarring because it's poorly formatted
etc so you can see we're running a list
through go format at the end there and
the running of the templates is just
there's nothing special that's going on
on the slide at all here one thing to
note though is I'd given the output file
a special name and that's to identify it
clearly when I'm looking at a file
within a directory as it generated file
now that's just a personal convention
that I have Jen underscore as the prefix
de generated files so that way it's just
clear to me when I'm listing a directory
for example oh there's a whole load of
generated files in here you will notice
that I haven't added what is another
convention in this package here which is
a comment at the top which should say
code generated by simple stringer
semicolons do not edit that's why if
you're looking at the file you're also
very clear that you shouldn't edit it so
that's one thing I should have done so
here we go we just talked through this
light here which is the actually
generating the output let's see it in
action again we're going to use go
generate here as our means of running
the code generator so here is our code
from essentially the problem statement
all the way back at the beginning all
we've done here is add that directive
which is the go generate directive to
call simple string up and here as you
can see we're just passing in the string
name of the type that we want to
actually generate the code generator
method for that's it that's all we've
had to do in order to introduce code
generation beyond actually writing the
code generator in this case of course so
let's see it in action clearly we've got
to run go generate first because I said
it's not part of the build process let's
take a look at the output file that's
been generated itself looks very similar
to the hand generated version that we
had before good okay kinda looks good so
far and now let's run it there we go
that needs a round of applause
I was trying to build some sort of drama
to that point in the presentation I
didn't work so simple so where are we
now so we've introduced cogeneration
we've talked about that and now we've
actually written up a very basic code
generator ourselves and hopefully this
is a sort of a bit of an inspiration as
to where in code you might also write
code generators because have you seen
that loading of syntax information and
type of information is really simple
understanding how to use that okay
that's a tiny bit may a bit more
involved and we'll come to that later on
and there are just so many different
creative ways in which you can integrate
code generations your workflow you might
look for type definitions you might look
for special comments any number of
things where you can look at either the
structure of the code or the types in
the code that can be used as effectively
daresay an entry point for your code
generator so there's plenty of things
that are wrong with this code here it's
not well tested it is definitely not
performant which is where the output of
stringer itself is very much optimized
but it works and that's a critical thing
for code generation as well as if it
works that's really all you care about
unless you then sort of run into issues
where that generated code is sort of a
bottleneck within benchmarks so the
focus is if it syntactically correct and
compiles and behaves as you need it to
you can give yourself a little pat on
the back that actually it's a good start
for your code generator lots of scope
for improvement but we'll leave it there
for now so as I talked about before go
generates itself has some problems in
that if you have dependencies between
packages and code generation or all of
them it's not necessary but it won't
necessarily do things in the right order
so that's what I mean by go generate
itself doesn't have dependency analysis
between packages it just runs it for all
the packages in some well-defined but
not particularly useful order it's slow
in that it always reruns code generators
as well it has no concept of do I need
to do anything here and it's also
somewhat hard to chain code generators
together where you have one code
generator that generates some output
that then serves as an input to another
code generator and sometimes that's
useful
so this is where I am this is the
motivating reason behind writing a tool
called go generate the go tool as
everybody uses it today is incredibly
efficient when it comes to doing build
tasks because of something called a
build artifact cache that means that
when you come to run something like go
install it doesn't rebuild everything
from scratch because it realizes I've
got nothing to do here
so that kind of feature sounds like
something we also want for code
generation and that's where go generate
the tool subtle difference no space
comes in it also is aware of effectively
the inputs to a code generator and then
doesn't rerun the code generator if it
notices those inputs haven't changed in
some way and so it also therefore keeps
track of the outputs that are generate
and that's why it's called an artifact
cache it's a wrapper around go generate
that's aware of these changes and inputs
or lack of changes therefore it's also
aware of the import dependencies so runs
code generators in imported packages
first and sort of walks the reverse
dependency graph as it goes the readme
actually gives plenty more details about
how good generate works I'd say it's in
a sort of beta stage so please report
any bugs that you see so why is it
actually useful let's just take a look
here
we're running go generate as a as a
command here instead of go space
generate and we're running it in a
special trace mode to see what it's
actually doing and that the comment
there that the timing there is how long
this command actually took so it's 4.1
seconds now you might think ok 4.1
seconds I've introduced artificial
delays within this process here 4.1
seconds of a code generation is that
good bad
well it's quite annoying if you're
actually doing a make some changes rerun
cogeneration workflow of just iterating
in that workflow particularly if the
inputs to the code generator excuse me
haven't changed so this is when you run
go generate for the first time but this
is where much like the go tool the
artifact cache comes in so when you run
it the second time it's significantly
faster because it's as well in this
particular case there's absolutely no
change to the input so I'm not going to
rerun the code generator at all so if
you have hundreds of code generation
steps
you're in your code base which is
conceivable you clearly don't want to be
looking at the abstract syntax tree
looking at the types for every single
code generator within every single
package every single time you run it so
this is where the artifact cache comes
into its own here please give it a try
if it works for you if it doesn't work
for you please report any bugs so where
is when where next for go generate
Michel again gave a really good
introduction about the go analysis
framework before and how the go analysis
framework with its suggested fixes to
users will ultimately want to be
included in goplease
which is the language server which will
be integrated with all editors that's
exactly where code generation should in
my opinion also end up is that it should
be nice and possible to also have
suggested fixes but also cogeneration
you can initiate and easily trigger from
within your editor so there's one huge
performance gain as well as that if like
the analysis checkers these things get
compiled in to go please they will be
much faster again than running even go
generate the special wrapper around go
generate so that's it as far as
cogeneration is concerned just to
briefly mention the golang tools
community as well because everything
that Michael talked about and everything
that I talked about effectively falls
under this banner of tools in Go Go lang
tools is a community a small little sub
community if I say of people who are
interested in writing tools and
understanding tools learning about tools
benefiting from tools and in tool by
tools we mean things like cogeneration
writing analysis frameworks your editor
plugin it's sort of all falls under that
very general header there and we have a
call that once a month and it's for
anyone who's interested in it or think
they might be interested in in this
space so please I've got links from the
slides here see the wiki for more
information so quick recap because I
think I'm well ahead of time here and
we're gonna do questions afterwards
we've examined the principles of code
generation we understand what it is we
understand how a code generator is
structured looked at some popular code
generators we've written a simple code
generator that can use as a template for
people writing their own code generators
in here we've seen how it fits into
developer workflow because that's a bit
of a missing
step at the moment people aren't
necessarily so clear how cogeneration
can or should fit into their workflow we
thought we've also seen as well how it
will fit into people's workflow if and
when cogeneration gets integrated with
go please and hopefully we've also
inspired everybody to join the
government tools community as well so a
few links here but other than that thank
you very much and thank you very much
the organizers again please make sure
that you find an organizer and say thank
you for running gopher con they yeah
they get all the data say the negative
feedback if there is any and I don't
think there is so much this year but do
make sure that you think of the
organizers as well for an amazing gopher
con UK and I think we pop I don't know
whether we have time to questions but
thank you
[Applause]
we have we have four minutes so I will
just take one or two questions and I'll
shout them at your home no go for I'll
repeat it up yeah ah may I refer you to
Roger so your hands question was in this
stringer actually generated output this
funky stuff going on here
that optimizes things in certain ways
optimizes for compiled output but also
errors that you see at compile time as
well
Roger Pepe is standing over there we'll
be able to answer the question for you
yeah yes
yeah so the question was about
dependencies and I made the point here
that go generates itself as a tool for
running your code generators has
problems because it's not dependency
aware so let's talk about the two parts
there's effectively the input that is
your source code to the code generator
that has dependencies because of things
like import statements yeah so your code
generating within package a that imports
package B you probably want to run your
code generation in package B first and
then run your code generation within
package a so that's go generate is not
aware of that and so will actually in
that situation run package a first then
package B which is not very helpful go
generate my tool says oh I spot there's
a dependency here let me ensure that I
run cogeneration and package B first and
then package a the second part of your
question was what if your code generator
adds dependencies itself go generate is
also the go tool itself is not aware of
those either but go generate my tool is
so if it adds further dependencies it
goes it says all hang on I've added a
dependency here and I've not yet run
cogeneration in that new dependency and
jumps over there and so it that graph
the import dependency graph is also
dynamic as you pointed out within
cogeneration and code generator the the
workflow needs to be aware of that and
that's where sort of my version of go
generate is aware of it does that help
okay one more question then it's
lunchtime I'm keeping you from lunch
Gifford yep yep I'm not using it in this
example here I'm just showing here the
different layers of abstraction that
exist your code generator could use it
could utilize SSA if it needed to slash
wanted to for its output it's entirely
up to you you don't need to use any of
these layers here as I said something
like Hugo has zero input is just a
template generator in it when you're
sort of creating new projects so if you
don't need any inputs don't use any you
don't need to load any code etc so it
it's it just depends what you're trying
to do with your code generator